[Musique]
top chrono c'est parti ah oui là elle y
va droit direct des bras regardez j'ai
dû marcher dans une flaque aux mains ça
t'as beau tir magnifique maintenant
c'est une flaque d'eau quand on a pu
marcher dans pire vous pensez à quoi
clair or mais bien sûr on a compris
remarque il paraît que ça porte chance
cela fait cinq jours que le nombre de
tests positifs au kovy 19 ne baissent
plus dans le pays voire augmente très
légèrement
comme on le voit sur ce graphique après
une baisse constante depuis la mi-avril
avec 21 cas positifs pour cent mille
habitants
le taux d'incidence lui aussi augmentent
sensiblement cette semaine d'un jour par
rapport aux au jour de la semaine
dernière chaque jour le virus a augmenté
de 30 à 40%
ça veut dire que on est à un niveau
faible de circulation du virus on n'a
pas écrasé complètement l'épidémie et
qu'on est payé pour savoir que ça peut
repartir assez vite on ne veut pas de
vague et on a aujourd'hui la possibilité
de l'éviter c'est des cycles en réalité
et à les alarmistes il y allait rassurer
c'est la force est de constater que ces
derniers jours ce sont les alarmistes
qui sont sur les plateaux de télévision
d'autres sportifs pas du tout à fait
d'accord rachid chez moi j'aime bien
regarder la télé et je change très vite
les chaînes devront pousser et très
musclé sur la savoie christophe ouais ok
peut très bien ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que
personne n'y échappera toutes personnes
non vaccinées sera contaminée par le
variant delta toute personne qui n'est
pas vacciné orale variant delta toutes
les expériences internationales nous le
montre ils sont de retour ils sont là
ils veulent nous imposer le ministère de
la santé une dictature sanitaire top
vous ne comprenez pas ça vous ne
comprenez rien ils veulent
voilà ils veulent qu'on soit au pas ryan
n'est pas vacciné et on a assez d'être
montrés du doigt je me sens presque à
regret c'est quoi mais je le vis un peu
mal chez moi on me dit de me vacciner je
veux travailler en dit de me vacciner
je suis pas encore senti 100% sûr je
préfère être assurés qu'on me dise un
petit peu ce qu'il y a pas de quoi il
est fait le vaccin pour ensuite me
lancer il est de retour dans les rues du
touquet le masque doit à nouveau être
porté par les habitants et les touristes
âgés de plus de 11 ans dans les endroits
les plus touristiques de la ville la
mesure est pas favorable le mans
accueilli vu le monde et c'est plus que
nécessaire pas c'est pour le bien de
tous je pense que c'est bien et je peux
vous assurer que je le soutiens
aujourd'hui de la population qui craint
une quatrième vague mais aussi des
commerçants des restaurateurs des
barreaux si j'ai fait la tournée des
bars avec deux sous préfet enfin toute
la tournée des bars j'ai évidemment
rendu visite aux patrons de bars et de
restaurants avec le effet samedi ce pas
ils sont tout sera dit moi pareil même
si on est vaccinés on est vacciné tous
les deux mais malgré tout pour habiter
dans une progression notamment avec
nouveau carillon qui peut y avoir le ses
façons d'être bête jusqu'au bout des
orteils au comme ses pieds
oui mais moi je milite encore pour le
maintien du masque tant qu'on n'est pas
sorti complètement l'extérieur à
l'extérieur ah bon donc on va tout à
leur parler du touquet pour vous c'est
pas un presque parce correction on sait
très bien que lorsqu'on dit plus de
masques à l'extérieur on ne porte plus à
l'intérieur j'avais très bien cette
règle docteur me faites pas dire si
c'est non on est on est on est des
citoyens mur et adultes quand même on
comprend en fait la différence entre
extérieur et intérieur et bien sûr le
nom c'est paris se sont pas contaminées
dans le stade ils se sont trop bas c'est
ce que prétend le savait mais alors
fermez tout monsieur fasquelle fermé
tout m'était des masses partout je veux
dire c'est insupportable en fait c'est
de lui qu'est ce que vous en savez oui
qu'est ce que vous en savez la vérité
c'est que nous le savons avec les
scientifiques précisément il n'y a pas
de contamination à l'extérieur et on a
lancé dans le double les effets mais
c'est fini lance des pierres mais des
pierres comme ça
alors bon il est lancé avec beaucoup de
force mais il atteint son but il a
invité ses quatorze meilleurs amis
d'accord et on est allé ce qu'il y avait
à la place de chacun de ses amis une
valise d'un million de dollars en
coupures de 20 pour les remercier de
l'avoir aidé quand il est arrivé à los
angeles qu'il avait pas de boulot qui
dormait sur les canapés des uns et des
autres est évidemment maintenant il a
extrêmement bien réussi c'est un homme
généreux qui a la mémoire alors avoir 14
meilleures amies c'est beaucoup quand
même longueur surtout celles qui sont
grenoble tandis qu'un très bon face aux
gentils oui et chantal jacques c'est
comme si tu est élu pape
c'était un grand homme c'était le
ministre était un grand homme président
at aniston un président est très grande
donc quand bernard anouma partir de la
pente il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
pleurer et moi je les encourage à partir
de quand je le suivrai parce que le pays
où va acquérir
je pense qu'il va te relever le pays qui
m'attire mais non on va pas trop élevé
de ces gens-là bizarre de voir le train
qui par là et qui nous laisse tout seul
milieu de rien
c'est pas un peu
liban non je je suis chez nous comme
chez moi oui mais partie conditions
c'est à dire que là où y'a rien vous
vous sentez chez vous très bien moi ce
que je constate chez olivier sur les
compte instagram que je suis notamment
des gens de ma génération c'est ce que
les gens sont en vacances en juillet et
en août à brisbane et en juin et ont
sabré oui c'est ça dans sa famille les
amis c'est s'être freelance aidés par
les aides qu vider ses salles la france
d'aujourd'hui ce sont des des freelances
en vacances
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon je rentre ses genoux
un exercice loin d'être simple je dors
ici parfois bien cela vous dormez sur
votre fauteuil de cech jouait
tranquillement quelques pintes de cidre
et je m'attache à faire un somme
ça m'arrive comme ça je tombe pas
ensuite je me réveille disons vers 8h à
quoi suis je monte m'allonger